I think you might enjoy some of the
clips I'm going to play for you here
sort of in the way that I enjoy horrible
things which I actually don't so this is
gonna be pretty horrifying we talked
yesterday at the end of the show about
schools reopening or not and Donald
Trump and Mike Pence's desire to see
schools open for what are what are
effectively political reasons Trump
believes schools are being kept closed
in order to hurt him politically now
that's not true but the fact that he
perceives it as political means that
forcing them to reopen is also political
in other words if keeping them closed
hurts him politically opening them he
believes helps him politically Donald
Trump tweeted two days ago in Germany
Denmark Norway Sweden and many other
countries schools are open with no
problems the Dems think it would be bad
for them politically if US schools
opened before the November election but
is important for the families enter for
the children and families may cut off
funding if not open now Trump is saying
we want to be like Europe we want to do
what Europe is doing but the reason
Sweden's not doing so well but Germany
Denmark and Norway the reason they're
doing well is because they handled the
virus completely differently if you want
to be doing what Europe is doing with
schools then you should have handled
coronavirus the way those countries
handled it from the beginning but that's
not really the focus today what we know
today is that cases are up deaths are up
summer camps have around the country in
Arkansas Missouri other places have had
to close because coronavirus outbreaks
have spread among the children and yet
Donald Trump and Mike Pence want schools
open period Trump and pence on Wednesday
at different events both were asked
about opening schools and they were
asked really specific questions about
what are the protocols how do you ensure
safety and their mouths moved and a ton
of stuff came out of their mouths but
they were completely unable or unwilling
to articulate just exactly how you open
schools safely so let's look at some of
these videos let's start with Mike Pence
pence was asked what exactly is the plan
to open school safely pence spoke for
about 90 seconds and he didn't answer
the question I'm going to play the full
answer for you because I want you
to see that he says nothing about the
question that was asked you're going to
hear the question or actually we're
gonna skip so you're not going to hear
the question we're gonna go right to
Mike Pence's answer and notice how Pence
doesn't state anything that would count
as an answer to the question well the
plan is to continue to do what we have
done from the very beginning as you
heard again this morning we're we're
leav 39 million tests that have been
performed all across this country
you heard Admiral Jerrod described the
extraordinary commitment in just one
community alone and what we've conveyed
to governor's is whatever support they
need to get kids back to school we're
going to make sure that they have we're
going to make sure that they have the
testing resources we're currently
educating estates on the possibility and
working with commercial labs on the
possibility of what's called pooling so
that literally there could be one test
run on say ten samples and and there are
there are particular universities that
already have built into their plans the
idea of testing all of their students at
the beginning of the academic year and
then doing surveillance testing but
we've made it very clear whether it's
testing whether it's personal protective
equipment or other resources that we
stand ready to provide those resources
to the states and and we reiterated that
once again to the governor's but the
good news is because of the historic
mobilization that President Trump
initiated we literally have hundreds of
millions of supplies of personal
protective equipment fifty nine thousand
ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile testing is scaling all across
America and we know that come the school
year will be ready to meet those needs
so let's analyze it and go through it
Penn says we're going to do what we've
done from the beginning well you failed
that has failed what you've done from
the beginning is one of the worst Korona
response to coronavirus responses in the
world trump Penn says we've tested 39
million people over a five-month period
great it's not an answer to how do you
open school safely Penn says we will
give them the support they need
not asking for support they're saying
it's not safe for you to decide that
they have to open and by the way they
failed to give States the support they
needed on testing so why would we trust
them now that they're going to give
schools the support that they need he
says we're looking at pool testing okay
I mean it's not really an answer to the
question he says some universities will
test their students okay he says we'll
send schools PPE if they want it now and
then he says Trump did a historic
mobilization that's a meaningless claim
it's untrue it was a historically bad
mobilization and then pence also
mentions we have ventilators there's not
an answer there because they don't know
how to open schools safely they don't
care if schools open safely they want
schools open in late August early
September with the hope that the that it
won't implode so quickly that they will
get a political benefit going into the
November election that's all they care
about
now CNN's Caitlin Collins had a good
question for pence if the if you insist
that these are decisions to be made
locally by schools why is Donald Trump
pressuring them to open and of course
Mike Pence is completely flummoxed by
the question decision so should it be up
to them to decide if they can safely
reopen and not the president saying he's
going to pressure them to do so well I
look we're gonna respect those unique
communities that may have challenges
that have rising cases or rising
positivity and but I think you look at
the nation as a whole
and what the President of the United
States has made clear as he thinks as we
reopen America we need to reopen America
schools so I think you see where where
that one is going if a community is
unique they get to decide Penn says I
guess otherwise Trump decides or
something like that and then pence also
says look at the nation as a whole we
had another single day new case record
we had multiple single day new case
records this week that's the nation as a
whole in fact if you want to make a case
for safe reopening you should say let's
not
look at the nation as a whole because
places like Florida and Texas and
Arizona and California and Oklahoma
where cases are spiking like crazy
they shouldn't open maybe you could make
the case that in states that have really
crushed the curve and even those states
I'm worried are going to start seeing
cases now as the numbers nationally go
so high maybe you make the case that you
could take the states that are doing
really well maybe even the counties that
are doing really well and look at
reopening there but when Penn says look
at the nation as a whole the nation as a
whole is setting new records for cases
and then pence also says we also push to
reopen churches as if that's some kind
of justification for opening schools
opening churches was a disaster and in
fact many churches have been a spreader
events spreading a spreader locations
clusters and that's a very bad idea now
then it's Trump Trump just says we have
to do it and everybody wants it Mike
Pence pretends to give an answer even
though he doesn't Trump doesn't even
pretend Trump just says we just have to
do it everybody wants to open so we want
to reopen the schools everybody wants it
the moms want it the dads want it the
kids want it it's time to do it you know
our mortality rate is right now at a
level that people don't talk about but
it's down tenfold tenfold so you look at
deaths are way down from this horrible
China virus and it's a disgrace that it
happened shouldn't have happened but it
did and the economy is coming back and
it's coming back strongly jobs or
setting records for two months ago they
set the record and then again almost
five million new jobs last month which
is a record and it broke our last record
of a month before so the numbers are
happening much faster than anybody
anticipated the stock market Nasdaq just
hit another record today and the markets
generally just really a very small
amount below where they were at the
height of of the market when we first
had to do this about four and a half
five months ago just meaningless
meandering
free association rambling of sorts sites
no evidence that everybody wants it says
the mortality rate is low remember
our death rate per capita is the ninth
highest in the world out of more than
200 countries and territories he says
there are job records he talks about the
Nasdaq or as he pronounces it the Nasdaq
and so between Mike Pence and Donald
Trump over the last 48 hours a lot of
bluster about we've got to open schools
everybody wants the schools open it's
all going to be safe no explanation of
how and why it's safe how they know it's
safe
how safety would be maintained what
would I mean listen another important
question is if these were serious people
who had a plan for how to safely open
then I would move to the question of
what data would say we have to reclose
in other words would it be a certain
number of cases among students what if a
teacher gets a case what if there's a
parent at home with a case is it case
growth rate or absolute numbers what
would be the metrics where you would say
we're going to do it but we're gonna
shut it down if X or Y I mean it's just
it's I'm acting like these are serious
people and that's that that's the
problem last thing I get the importance
of opening schools a lot of parents
can't work if the kids aren't in school
this is huge economically it's gonna be
worse economically if you open schools
and the kids get the virus and the
teachers get the virus and the parents
get the but that will be much worse
economically Tuesday 8:00 p.m. David
Pakman show chess tournament register
for free at david pakman.com slash chess
and remember to get our daily audio
podcast on itunes stitcher
Spotify or whatever your favorite
podcasting app is the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Carolyn
Padgett and chase Venus Carolyn and
chase thank you so much for your support
and also a big thank you a big hug to
Pamela
Abraham Pamela has been a member for
almost 5 years it is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day
grab a membership at join pakman.com
let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 starting with our caller from the old
stomping grounds of the David Pakman
show in the 4-1 3 area code who's
calling today from 4 1 3 hello yes
that's you yes you are hey I'm not sure
if you've heard about this but I
recently updated their guidelines and
they're basically saying that every one
every 10 cents which is opening only for
online classes and they're things that
if the campus is open only for online
classes and all the international
support themselves or transfer to a
college which is offering and putting
yes let me see if I can let me let me
see if I can explain it to the audience
and in the meantime if we're on
speakerphone or you're using a Bluetooth
or something please turn it off we can
barely understand you but let me explain
to the audience what you're saying
we there has been an autumn people just
just barely so what what's going on is
many schools are going to be online only
in the fall and what the Trump
administration is okay I'm gonna let you
go and then we'll I'm not exactly sure
what's going on there but maybe we can
be at a better connection but the Trump
administration is saying they are going
to do is if you are a foreign student
here on a visa and your school is going
online only they are essentially saying
you've got to go you're gonna have to do
your online classes from your home
country it's becoming a very very big
political disagreement and for important
reasons and we'll have probably a more
detailed report on it at some point in
the future let's go next to our caller
from the 7:07 area code who's calling
today from 7:07 yes I can this is Bart
from California hey Bart what's going on
Bart are you there okay
we lost Bart very very good day let's go
next to our caller from the eight one
six area code who's calling today from
eight one six hey David this is jazz
from Kansas City Missouri hey jazz
what's going on uh so I was calling to
ask you about how you're voting in
November okay specifically on a ballot
measure it looks like Massachusetts will
probably have rank-choice voting on the
ballot will you be voting for it I've
not seen the language of it I actually
didn't I need to get schooled up on
what's on the ballot in in November so
the answer is depending on how it is
written I very well may and I we've I've
done a lot of interviews and segments on
a number of different voting systems
there's the the sort of a standard
configuration of rank-choice voting
they're a single transferable vote
there's a bunch of different
configurations and I like a lot of them
some of them are less than perfectly
structured and so I need to look at how
it's written but that is certainly
something I would consider voting for
until I actually see the text of the of
the initiative it I wouldn't want to say
for sure actually
Maine has Instant Runoff voting I'm
pretty sure that's what Massachusetts is
proposing and it's the it seems like the
easiest to implement system with and
given our current constitutional
structure but yeah that's a
consideration which is sometimes the
best system is more complex
constitutionally to implement and you
also don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good as someone
someone once said I don't know who yeah
yeah well first-past-the-post is
arguably the worst right but do you
think progressives should focus on
electoral reform like on ballot in
issues such as the main one and the
massachusett absolutely so what for for
several years now one of the frame the
framework I've been prioritizing is we
need to fix how politics is financed and
we need to fix how we vote and this can
include getting rid of
first-past-the-post this can include
getting away from the electoral college
system so yeah it's like if you care
about education or abortion or climate
or whatever to really make progress on
these issues you've got to fix some of
the structural problems that we have
healthcare I would consider one of those
structural problems in the sense that if
you are stuck at a job merely to avoid
losing health insurance it's going to be
difficult to be an activist for what you
care about so absolutely this should be
a priority for progressives okay and one
last question is your mind sure um since
Maine has rank-choice voting now and
they're gonna be voting in 2020 but the
rank-choice voting the Instant Runoff
how would you feel about progressives in
Maine putting Lisa Savage the Green
Party candidate as their
in the race against Susan Collins I know
nothing about her so I would have to
know I mean I get the question is more
of a mathematical question you can vote
for the Green Party candidate without
helping Susan Collins if you have a
system other than first-past-the-post
but but even still given that I know
nothing about her it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to say yes do it
because who know I just don't know
enough about her right right I was more
so just asking generally if under a
Instant Runoff system you think that
voting Green Party as number one would
be a good idea only if you support the
Green Party what a statement that I can
say more generally is with such a system
you can vote for the person you most
agree with without fear that you may be
helping the person you're most opposed
to that would be how I would generalize
the rule all right yeah cool all right
my friend thank you very much for the
phone call appreciate hearing from you
let's go to let's go to our friend
dontel from Florida Don tell our how are
things going down there what would the
virus exploding Don teller are we muted
we can't hear you alright Don tell we're
gonna one more opportunity I wanted to
hear from you Don tell but we're not
you're not coming through it all all
right no Don tell that's too bad was
wanted to hear from him let's go to our
caller from the nine one three area code
who's calling today from nine one three
hi David can you hear me yes I can who's
this cool this is Andrew from the Boston
area my question for you is what can be
done to sever the ties between property
taxes and school funding that's my
question for you yeah this is a great
question because you have this
perpetuating cycle in a lot of areas
where the richer areas with higher
property values are often collecting
more prop
taxes and those taxes are used to fund
schools which make those schools better
which makes more people want to move
into those areas which often drives up
property values even more making the
properties less accessible and you get
situations that essentially I mean the
interview earlier this week with Daniel
Markovitz about the idea of a
meritocracy not not being what we had
not also not being ideal in its extreme
form but also not being what we have is
related exactly to this issue so I've
seen different proposals I mean in in to
put it very simply you can find other
funding you could you could just say
property taxes are no longer going to be
directly funding the school so for
example property taxes may be pooled or
partially pooled at the state level and
then redistributed out now it not a
hundred percent so if you have a place
with really high property taxes they
would send a portion of the taxes to the
state a place with lower property tax of
receipts would send a portion to the
state and then the state would sort of
redistribute more evenly to try to
improve the schools that that are not
quite so good but of course the people
that are paying the higher property
taxes are going to resist that they're
going to say wait I'm paying more so
that my kids can go to good schools and
by living here I'm actually helping
somebody somewhere else and that people
are going to be furious about that so if
the question is how could it be done
mathematically you'd redistribute you
you have a common pool and redistribute
if the question is how do you do it
politically I have no idea yeah and um
are there any leaders right now who are
running with this kind of at the top of
their platform that we can be promoting
that's my second question and it's kind
of hard not not that I'm aware of I mean
it's it's certainly possible I'm not
aware of anybody who's making that their
issue but that doesn't mean it doesn't
exist
alright great thanks David alright great
to hear from you excellent question
thank you for the call let's go to our
caller from the nine eight five area
code who's calling today from nine eight
five
hi my name is Christian Matt and I'm
calling from Baton Rouge Louisiana
what's going on Christian um
hey how you doing it's kind of hard to
hear you but my question was so I
listened to you and I also listened to
Ben Shapiro show okay and so it seems
like you guys on some of the same topics
like for instance like the Trump
speeches you all have the exact opposite
points of view on those shocking so I
guess my question is how is it
how are those opposite points of view
from the two sides like reconcilable in
the current like climate we're in I
don't think they are I mean I think that
it's sadly intractable I don't I I don't
watch ben shapiro so i don't know what
he said but earlier this week I covered
Tucker Carlson's reaction to Trump's
Mount Rushmore speech and Tucker Carlson
I think called it maybe Trump's best
speech ever and what was so interesting
to me about it was it was a speech of
rhetoric it was not a speech of policy
so if the question if what you want to
see in a speech is what accomplishments
does Trump claim from his first term and
what is he going to do in his second
term you didn't get that in Trump speech
what you got from Trump speech was a dog
whistle red-meat rhetoric about were
fighting Marxists and all this these
crazy you know straw men that don't
exist
the reason Tucker Carlson liked it was
that it was the type of rhetoric that
Carlson himself uses to bamboozle his
audience it's essentially what Trump is
doing so we're looking at these things
with completely different standards so I
don't know if the views are reconcilable
quite frankly okay all right no problem
you know it's a very pessimistic
response but I think it's it's the you
know it's the reality let's go next to
our caller from the 585 area code who's
calling today from 585 hey David this is
James from Rochester New York James how
are you oh my pleasure thanks yeah
you're breaking up a bit but I could
hear your callers okay oh well I was
calling to ask have you heard about this
paper called The Epoch Times and what do
you think about it because to me it
strikes me as basically a right-wing
conspiracy paper but it advertises
itself as a non biased news source and
my father actually just subscribed to it
oh my god thinking that it was a non
biased news source oh so listen I I
don't know that much about it I get a
lot of emails from viewers saying that
their ads are coming up before my videos
on YouTube which of course I have no
control over that's not they're not like
an advertiser specifically with the
david pakman show I recently read that
the epic times is run by the same guy
that runs that new app parlor this
conservative version of Facebook or
Twitter or whatever and that guy if it
is the same guy he had been offering 20
grand as a bounty for any progressive
influencer with more than 50,000 Twitter
followers to sign up on parlor which I
did earlier this week I've not gotten my
$20,000 yet which may they may have been
lying about that James I'm not totally
sure but no it is not an unbiased
newspaper it seems to be a conspiracy
right organization from the few clips
I've seen reminiscent of Oh a n and you
know I would try to do an intervention
with your dad quite frankly because if
he's if he's subscribing if he's paying
for that stuff believing it's unbiased
then we've got to rescue him thanks yeah
you're breaking up but I think I got the
gist of it all right thank you all right
appreciate it very good I am gonna go to
a quick break I am going to try to see
if maybe I changed the microphone that
viewers are hearing me through and then
we will go right back to the phone so if
you are holding please don't hang up
we'll go back to the phones after this
short break
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him welcome
back to the David Pakman show
welcome back let's go back to the phone
lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and see if I
have dealt with my audio issues we're
going to go to our caller from the 6:09
area code who's calling today from 6:09
let me yes it is hey David alright
you've gone completely underwater so
unfortunately I'm gonna have to let you
go and we'll have to try someone else
let's go to our caller from the 703 area
code who's calling today from 7:03 hi
can you hear me yes I can okay oh yeah
your audio better um so hey David I was
just wondering um you've mentioned a lot
that a large problem the US has is not
being respected by our allies yes and I
was just wondering how you would get
people specifically like on the right
prioritize that because a lot of people
you know that I know don't really think
that you know we should be respected or
you don't really think it's worth it
they don't care anyway yeah well like
not they don't care you know they it's
like you know they actively actively
don't want to be like respected as a
country which cuz they just think that
Europeans and Canadians like to hate
them so like why should why should they
even bother you know like how do we
how would we like in theory get rid of
that yeah I mean some of some of them
actually see it as a badge of honor
they're like why do we care if [ __ ]
Europeans like us we don't want them to
like us that means we're doing what's
good for America I mean listen I I
hesitate to ever recommend trying to
appeal to the rights values because
their values are often so misguided but
I wonder would the right care more about
the u.s. being respected around the
world if they saw it as a national
security issue
like if they if they were convinced that
we are safer by being respected around
the world then maybe we could get them
to understand the importance of not
being a laughingstock I don't I mean I'm
thinking out loud here I don't know the
answer yeah before you actually you know
try and and very like get respected by
the rest of the world which you know in
reality is mainly just Europe you have
to you know convince you know people
that hey this is actually something
that's worthwhile and I think you know
you have to do that first to pause the
country doesn't tell actively you know
doesn't really want to be respected and
I mean you can't really you can't really
you know pursue a policy that you know
you know get the u.s. you know respected
around the world again because you know
it's just kind of fruitless but I
totally agree I mean you have a CISO so
for example you know on climate change
under Donald Trump
the US has increasingly not even invited
to take part in some of the important
multinational conversations that are
happening about that but that doesn't
bother the right you know a huge part of
the right thinks climate change is a
hoax another part of the right believes
that the u.s. can just fix every problem
buy ourselves a sort of isolationist
mentality so we don't need to be part of
these multinational conversate
multilateral conversations so you are
100% right that if they don't care it's
not going to be any it's not going to be
a bargaining stick if they don't care
about being respected to begin with my
pleasure thank you for the call great to
hear from you let's go next to our
caller from the nine seven eight area
code who's calling today from nine seven
eight
hi can you hear me yes I can't who's
this my name is Mark I live in
Framingham great and Mark please just
keep the phone you're coming in shot out
of a cannon very very hot just try to
either talk a little more quietly or
maybe keep the II had the mouthpiece a
little further from your mouth okay in
some sense all right all right well
first I'd like to know what do you think
makes Trump in anomaly because you've
said that you think Trump is just
uniquely bad considering that Bush
invaded nations that were still in after
decades against international law even
though the UN said there weren't weapons
of mass destruction how is Trump any
more of a corrupt evil gangster than
Bush was that's my first question so
first we have a sort of category error
which is you are it sounds like you're
saying let's supply the sort of foreign
policy standards that we would apply to
typical neo-cons
to Donald Trump in order to evaluate
them against each other and what I would
assert is that we're dealing with
category differences Donald Trump is bad
in a way that is very different than how
george w bush was bad and of course if
you're looking for someone to defend
george w bush that's certainly not going
to be me we spent you know the the
greater part of Bush's presidency
pointing out all of the ways in which
bush was bad Don Donald Trump is bad in
a in a different way and I'll give you
one example that I think is relevant
george w bush's foreign policy is the
disgusting neocon foreign policy of
people like john bolton and you know
Wolfowitz and rumsfeld and so on and so
forth and that's absolutely horrible but
george w bush would not have screwed up
coronavirus the way Donald Trump did and
this is not praise of Bush and Bush it
was a disaster on Katrina mostly for
different reasons but even someone as
uniquely horrible as Bush from the
foreign policy perspective would not
have messed this up in the way that
Donald Trump did
George W Bush made the wrong foreign
policy decisions with Iraq but he didn't
ruin so many of our long-standing
alliances and get the United States to
be essentially ignored in large swaths
of the global decisions that have to be
made so I I just think that there's a
category difference the ways in which I
criticize Bush are different
fundamentally than the ways in which
Trump has been an embarrassing failure
all right well what do you don't you
think that also the NSA and Patriot and
the Patriot Act by Bush were also things
that were also evil examples of domestic
policy as well yet but both of those
contained horrible provisions yes I
agree with that okay and my last
question which is just a total
irrelevant to the first two I know
you're a big chess player if someone
were trying to get into chess what
resources do you think would be best for
a beginner I I would just go on YouTube
and just google chess for beginners and
you'll find hundreds of hours of simple
videos just getting people introduced to
the concepts and then also Lee chess org
slash practice has a bunch of free
resources for just starting to learn the
basics okay thank you
all right great appreciate the phone
call thank you so much let's go next to
our caller from the nine five four area
code 954 has been holding on for a
little while who's this where you're
calling from me yes it is what's up
David it's actually Sebastian calling in
from Miami great what's going on well I
want to first start by saying that to
this day I love your show I actually was
the right winger who called in a few
months ago asking for career advice for
anyone listening that video still up if
you want to go check it out okay so do
you remember that er I don't I'm sorry
no it's alright you get a bunch of calls
but I think today's question is going to
be a lot more straightforward okay
I have a few but let's just see how many
I could get in here so as you may know
Kanye has announced his bid for
presidency this week you know previously
we saw his relationship with Trump it's
a positive so really you know it might
just sound kind of weird to question but
I have this this kind of like underlying
feeling that it might be some type of
Trump administration strategy to absorb
that crucial black Bo you know would
that just be nonsense I mean you're not
the first person to bring this up to me
the idea would be Trump and Kanye are
friends Joe Biden right now has 92
percent from black voters what better
way to hurt Biden than by having a black
a prominent black entrepreneur and
musical artist run and take a little bit
of the black vote from Biden that so so
the motive would certainly be there I
think what it misses is that I don't
believe black folks are going to vote
for Kanye who were otherwise going to
vote for Biden there maybe Kanye fans
who weren't even planning to vote
remember half the country doesn't vote
who I guess might vote for Kanye even
though he's still as far as I know to
this day he's not formally running
anywhere he just said he's running but I
think that it's fundamentally you know
insulting and dismissive of the black
community to if that's your plan to
imagine that the black community is just
going to vote for any black guy who runs
it is not borne out by the evidence and
I think it's a bad strategy if that's
the strategy yeah I also heard that he's
missed some crucial deadlines so I don't
even think it would be possible and it
comes down to it would you actually ever
consider voting Kanye over Trump I guess
you could you would probably go anything
other than Trump yeah I mean I I don't
know about that you know it's not
occurred to me that that's ever a
position I would be in so I'm gonna opt
out of even answering that but I am no
fan of Kanye he seems extremely unstable
I mean over Trump it's like it's hard to
justify voting for Trump
for anyone that'd be a tough one I don't
know what I would do okay let me just
see if you can answer this one
Ghislaine maxwell she was just arrested
and indicted and from what i heard
yesterday she has like a bargaining
chips which is supposedly a bunch of
videos pictures or whatever that's
incriminating a lot of public figures
and influencers do you have any ideas
some of the names we might be seeing in
your future
I have absolutely no idea I'm not going
to put the cart before before the horse
on that and I am waiting to see if and
what comes of it and I've also not read
the allegations that you're citing all
right Sebastian I've got a lot of people
holding so I'm gonna move on I I'm it
sounds like you had a litany of
questions but I'm gonna move on so to
make sure some other folks get an
opportunity let's go to our caller from
the 4:06
area code who's calling from 406 today
deadly yes it is who's this oh hi I am
calling from to make my first vehicle
father you are indeed the first Jamaican
caller we've ever had
tightly so drizzle with it particularly
I came onto this listing because
initially because of Kyle and then I was
drawn into your comments because I think
was an extent you have a little bit more
realistic approach to progresses
progress with him then I like highly no
and I like or we particularly but I
think your approach is more realistic
thank my question to you do my questions
even though it is sometimes I wonder if
you're too consumed by your critique of
Trump so sometimes you might miss why
tip is embodied in is so because I like
to do what I'm trying to say the latter
the problem like that Trump has like
many people doing home but I will fix it
and
I don't think your critique properly
address some of those issues I totally
understand what you're saying yeah I
mean listen it's not I'm not even
suffering from the delusion that Biden
would fix all of the problems of Trump
the analogy I've been using is we just
need to get the ball back so we have the
opportunity of putting some points on
the board and we're not going to put all
of the points on the board with Joe
Biden but it's it's the opportunity now
what's going on in the back are you in a
restaurant it sounds extremely loud
there no no my mother in it she was
quiet
oh is that right it sounds like hot pots
and pans yeah no listen I mean you're
you're bringing I I agree with you I
take no qualms with you if I have given
anyone the impression that Joe Biden
fixes all of the problems that are
evident with Trump that's not the case
but some problems would be fixed and we
would stop doing as much damage and and
it's a harm reduction approach I make no
qualms about that okay I doing this only
say whoever there is what do I say I'm
work in Kannamma concerns especially in
this time given that like for example
Dennis with the bellows that right after
the coronavirus yeah people are pointing
to if it was a job and the same thing
would have like they're both identical
an economical skill when enough cultural
skill they're different and some people
are pointing that's not you know so
here's where I take a little bit of
issue with what you're pointing out if
the argument is Biden would also have
done bailouts yes
Biden would also have done bailouts
here's what I think the differences
would have been if J if Trump had been
Biden instead he would have listened
more to the medical science community
from the beginning and the pandemic
would never have been as bad and thus it
would have necessitated it would not
have necessitated the same economic
reaction and my belief is that it would
have been done in a less crony istic way
under Joe Biden than Donald Trump so yes
they both would have done bailouts but I
think we would be far better off in
total economically if it had been Joe
Biden at the helm
rather than Donald Trump I want this
fish because I know you have another
caller on the phone what what I wanted
to another question I wanted Artie is
regarding this free speech stuff and my
critique of the left tool is that the
left is giving the right ammonition to
to believe that they are the what the
so-called fighters are free speech and
that's to an extent drive me crazy
because I think some people in the right
take this as a opportunity to say what
they would really care for is free
speech but Wendell it is so like the
kinds of culture the walk ISM it kind of
give them a monition to feel that be I
completely agree with you the the entire
idea or meme of the left is against open
discussion and the right is for it the
left wants to cancel everything and the
right wants to hear every I think it's I
think it's you're completely correct in
your analysis and if we've got to take
the narrative back my friend I'm gonna
let you go it sounds like things it
sounds like the main course is about to
be served
yeah sure
thank you first call from Jamaica we
absolutely love it and on that note
let's go out on a high we are going to
go to a break I apologize I was not able
to get to everybody today but we did
hear from some great great people and I
will take calls again the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
okay welcome back let's get right into
audience questions first one David if
Biden gets elected in November what do
progressive be next
so disclaimer disclaimer don't put the
cart before the horse everybody's got to
go vote there is no guarantee that Joe
Biden is going to get elected
Republicans are certainly planning some
October surprises we don't even know
what they are yet but certainly claiming
victory over coronavirus may be an
emergency use vaccine maybe more lies
about economic numbers who even knows
but do not put the cart before the horse
every single one of us needs to go out
and vote here is the analogy I've been
using to talk about a possible Biden
victory over Trump Biden winning doesn't
score us any points Biden winning gives
us the ball back we've been playing
defense the entire time Trump has been
president so if we get the ball back
that's when we have to then put together
our strategy for how to put some points
on the board now this reminds me of the
importance of getting control of the
Senate and maintaining control in the
house because Joe Biden is not the most
progressive candidate but he's not
likely to veto legislation that makes it
through the House and Senate now the
devil is in the details there you might
imagine something like Medicare for all
and you might say Biden would veto
Medicare for all he says he's not for it
well Medicare for all is not going to
pass the Senate right that's what you
and this is not don't attack the
messenger even many Democratic senators
don't support Medicare for all and if
the Democrats get a majority in the
Senate it would be a small one maybe
with 53 or 54 senators Medicare for all
is not going to make it to Joe Biden's
desk so let's not let's think of you
know more realistic examples and
Virginia is a very realistic example
you've got a moderate Democratic
governor with a Democratic legislature
and they've gotten progressive things
done and we've seen Virginia move to the
left significantly even with a moderate
Democratic governor but like I've said
before a Biden win is the start so
extend house control hopefully take
control of the Senate and then
in the immediate Joe Biden needs to be
pressured to reverse the insane Trump
executive orders that have accumulated
while Donald Trump has been in the Oval
Office and then the House and Senate
need to go to work
Biden is going to have to be pushed and
he's going to have to be pushed hard and
what what I've been trying to
communicate for some time now is even if
Biden isn't as progressive as Bernie and
he's nowhere near as progressive as
Bernie Sanders Biden is running on what
if he were elected president would be
the most progressive platform that a
sitting president has had just think
through this right Biden is accused by
many of being barely a centrist there's
people say this guy is almost like a
moderate Republican if you look at
Biden's tax plan the way I did on Monday
this week it's well to the left of
Barack Obama's if you look at the things
that are in Biden's tax plan abolishing
the lower rate for capital gains
dramatically expanding the social
security tax on people earning above
$400,000 a year eliminating the
stepped-up basis I mean there's not even
a what what Joe Biden wants to do tax
wise is well to the left of Barack Obama
if you look at Biden's health care plan
it's obviously not Medicare for all
but it is Obama care plus a bunch of
stuff to the left of Obama including
Biden has said he would be supportive of
lowering the age for Medicare and a
bunch of other things it is not Medicare
for all but the point is if Biden gets
it done what he wants to do would be the
leftmost position public option etc it's
Obot what Obama started from which is
public option with more stuff like
lowering the Medicare age Biden supports
the green New Deal as a framework and
that is something that I mean green New
Deal wasn't even a term back then so my
point is not that Biden is the uber
progressive hero
my point is Biden has already made it
clear that if he were president his
policy would be the most progressive of
anyone who has been president not who
has run okay and he's got to be held to
it and he has to be given the ability
through the House and Senate to actually
get things done and that's why
if Biden gets elected we've gotten the
ball back that's when the offense starts
next question today is about the economy
David how is Donald Trump still polling
better than Joe Biden on the economy
this is a really good question and it
gets to a lot of the way that
Republicans have operated for a very
long time you've got a recession going
on
Trump is down eight nine ten twelve
points nationally to Joe Biden and yet
he is still polling better than Biden on
the economy morning consult has Trump
plus nine on the economy CNN has Trump
plus twelve on the economy YouGov has
Trump plus five a Quinnipiac says Biden
is plus one on the economy but that's
way less than on basically every other
issue for Biden Harvard Harris poll says
Trump is plus ten on the economy so a
couple different things number one the
the lead is diminishing so if you look
at the trend line Trump is leading Biden
by less and less on handling the economy
over time there is a meme there's a
tendency to think that Republicans are
just better on the economy than
Democrats now the reality is that that's
a historical we did a analysis we did an
analysis earlier this week about the
stock market under Democrats versus
Republicans does far better under
Democrats than under Republicans
unemployment tends to be lower we've
looked at all the numbers but in
practice Trump also doesn't know a damn
thing about the economy Trump didn't
know about currency valuations he called
Michael Flynn at 3:00 a.m. and said do
we want a weak currency or a strong
currency which is good and Flynn said
talk to an economist Trump has no idea
on trade Trump believes that the stock
market tells us how an economy is doing
so part of it is that a lot of voters
also think those same things Trump
thinks to figure out how the economy is
doing you look at the stock market a lot
of voters think the same thing and in
fact they tweet me all the time and say
the economy is doing great because the
stock market is doing great a lot of
what also needs to be considered is that
Republicans tend to do
things economically that will have a
short-term focus how many jobs can we
create this month even though reopening
early will hurt the economy's in the
long run and a lot of the jobs jobs are
crappy right
how many stock market points can we gain
today even its if it's with cash
injections that are short-sighted and
won't really improve the economy in the
long run so that's a really important
thing also to consider which is
Republicans are far more likely than
Democrats to do things that improve the
optics of the economy in the short term
but don't really improve it in the long
term and this is where a lot of this
translates into the general belief that
Republicans are just better for your
paycheck you know better for your
pocketbook or better for your bank
account it's mathematically untrue but
unfortunately these memes are pretty
sticky and just remember the fact stocks
do better under Democrats unemployment
is lower under Democrats just about
every economic indicator we've looked at
a bunch of others although I'm
forgetting them now they look better
under Democrats and we shouldn't allow
them to take the narrative away and the
diminishing lead that Donald Trump has
on Joe Biden in terms of expected
handling of the economy is a sign that
at least the disastrous economic
situation we have right now is affecting
Donald Trump we thought maybe he's
Teflon Teflon Don maybe nothing will
affect him coronavirus the subsequent
economic collapse and his reaction to
the protests against police brutality
have hurt him very much as approval down
to 38% okay another question that came
in David a Joe Biden is expected to
select his vice president around August
1st who do you think would hurt Biden
the most so earlier another one was it
last week I said that I believe
Elizabeth Warren should be Joe Biden's
vice presidential pick this is a
different question not who would be best
but who would be worst so the first
thing is to understand what is the goal
of selecting a vice president there's
essentially two goals one don't cause a
problem for the presidential candidate
so Sarah Palin did did not help John
McCain back in 2008 now McCain was
already losing but Palin
was a cartoonish sideshow and certainly
did not help and number two can you
increase the electorate can you bring in
some additional people to bolster
support for the presidential candidate
so you look at someone like Paul Ryan
Paul Ryan didn't do much one way or the
other for Romney in terms of creating
scandals or saying crazy things arguably
Paul Ryan maybe helped Romney a little
bit when it comes to the electorate
being from where was Ryan from Virginia
I think Romney being you know a massive
former Massachusetts governor
maybe not didn't really do much one way
or the other Mike Pence didn't do much
for Trump in terms of bad news headlines
he just stayed out of the way but maybe
Pence helped in the Midwest maybe Pence
helped with the evangelical vote which
ultimately mostly went to Donald Trump
anyway I believe if Joe Biden were to
choose Hillary Clinton it would probably
be bad that would probably hurt him if
Joe Biden were to choose you know an
actual Republican if Joe Biden announces
I don't know its head Cruz is my running
mate I think it's a real problem for
Biden I think that that but obviously
he's not going to do that and if Joe
Biden picks someone with a lot of
baggage that can be attacked that would
be a problem so for example Amy
Klobuchar it was revealed in the
aftermath of the killing of George Floyd
that she had been involved in decisions
not to go after Derek shavon who
ultimately is the officer that killed
George Floyd would the knee to the neck
once that went public it was obvious
that Clovis Shar was damaged in terms of
a vice presidential candidate she came
out and said I'm dropping out because
there should be a woman of color but it
was clear at that point she wasn't going
to be selected anyway that type of
baggage could be damaging to Joe Biden
obviously it's not going to be Clovis
Shar now I got a couple emails from
people who said the Native American
thing would be baggage for Elizabeth
Warren I don't know that it would I
really don't know that it would I think
listen if you want to talk about baggage
Kamala Harris is record as California
Attorney General prosecuting the war on
drugs and putting a lot of black folks
in in jail in prison in prison I think
that that may be baggage that Biden does
not need but I may be wrong there so
again the the point here is when you
pick a VP you want someone who's not
going to get a ton of attention because
typically it will be negative attention
number two you want someone who maybe
can help you in terms of expanding your
base of support and number three you
want someone who's not going to bring
some kind of baggage that is going to
disproportionately become a subject
matter for discussion if you disagree
with me let me know we've got a great
bonus show for you today to become a
member and get the bonus show you need
only go to join pakman.com and sign up
to exciting things going on next week
Tuesday night at 8 p.m. Eastern the 3rd
David Pakman show chess tournament it
will be at david pakman.com slash chess
you can go there now and register for
free for the tournament this is all free
I'm not selling anything big shocker to
a lot of people nothing is being sold
here just a community building
opportunity david pakman.com slash chess
register for free tournament 8 p.m. on
Tuesday the 14th number 2 also on
Tuesday the 14th we will be doing a
single day membership special the reason
we're doing it is a sad reason you might
think July 14th what's that what's the
deal back in 2019 in early July we did a
fourth of July special hundreds of
people signed up all those memberships
came due for renewal a few days ago and
because of the virus hundreds of those
people who signed up in 2019 couldn't
afford to renew I got a lot of email
saying I'm sorry David I want to support
you but I can't so we lost hundreds of
members in the first four days of July
not good so we're trying to counteract
that and sort of Rhian Tuesday we'll do
a mailing with a single day membership
special it'll be a beautiful discount
you want to be notified about it just
get on my mailing list at david
pakman.com we will see you on today's
bonus show and then next week
you